there is a critical distinction between
frankness and inhumanity it is the
difference between delivering a harsh
truth and compassion and lobbying
insults with Reckless abandon it's the
difference between calling someone
morbidly obese and a and a fat F he says
the actual word though this I'm tired of
being nice mentality is dumb I've never
sugarcoated the truth to avoid hurt
feelings it's impossible to speak bold
truths directly and without euphemism
and draw moral lines in the sand while
also not engaging in vicious name
calling it's not that hard
uh he goes on but I think the point here
is
this is one of the reasons why I believe
the right
could lose one of the biggest weaknesses
of the right everything we talked about
uh in the previous segments you've got
January 6 defendants who walked into a
building where the cops opened the door
for them and they're facing years
probably end up getting a couple years
like like uh like the Q Shaman he got
convicted sentenced to four years and
the video shows the police are actually
escorting him around the building but
sure enough that's that's all it takes
when they lie